hey toss me that extension uh  come join it's the annual afc north  snowball fight don't worry the  division's not like it was in the old  days okay you lovable scamps i'm in  morphy and then put me back out there  dub  the war is nearly over please wait for  me  my broken cannon only makes me look  cooler next thanks y'all i made us all  hot cocoa  [Music]  time to put these hall of fame legs to  work ow  justin tucker your normally patrice  affiliates bear two psychedelma  see haters i caught one okay i can't  catch everything this is worse than the  nfc west sand fights  get rekt fam fine i'm awake now coach  why aren't we rebuilding eh i'm holding  you back  but i forgot to trap your successors  [Music]  tell me i've been a good man  we're not dead yet  [Music]  here's the zack wrap about his accra get  a little hungry i had a zack snack  christmas time i take his act nap and  that's a zack wrap on my zac rap  you said zack rap four times kid